[Music]
Chopra they made their love Instagram
official with an engagement party in
India over the weekend and today the
couple continues to spread their joy by
giving back
[Applause]
the bride-to-be showed off her bollywood
dance moves in a place dear to her heart
st. Catharines orphanage and Mumbai her
fiance got the seal of approval from the
girls after serenading them with an
acapella version of Love Bug Branca
captain the sweet moment 12 years of
knowing these girls and immense they get
all lovestruck Nick and his parents
arrived in India last week carrying a
gigantic Tiffany's bag perhaps a gift
for their daughter-in-law tobe after
weeks of speculation the couple finally
confirmed their engagement on Saturday
with a series of intimate photos from
their traditional roca ceremony a
significant pre-wedding ritual and
Indian culture they later celebrated
with family and friends Priyanka
flashing that 5 carat engagement ring
[Music]
meanwhile we were with Priyanka
quantico's co-star blair Underwood at
the premiere of his new movie the after
party he hasn't met Nick yet but he had
this advice for him what I can say she's
a good people she's a hard worker they
gotta work out those schedules you know
because that's a hard-working woman
right then
[Music]